foreign
George Campbell here co-host of the
Ramsey Show and we're back again with
another installment of the best of the
Ramsay show if you've never seen a Dave
Ramsey rant you are in for a treat I
could listen to this guy rant about
anything so get ready for some hot takes
on student loans the metaverse and
scummy companies trying to rip people
off buckle up buttercup
Mark is with us in Boston hey Mark
welcome to the Ramsey Show
thanks Dave really appreciate how you
doing better than I deserve how can we
help
yeah so I'll uh I'll throw you a little
backstory here I'm uh currently an
undergraduate student
um full-time enrolled I have a full
tuition scholarship I'm also a resident
advisor so I don't pay room and board
either so I actually uh nothing at the
end of each semester
um recently I just bought a car I have
about a ten thousand dollars in debt on
that
um there's a obviously a large push from
the left pushing for uh student loan
forgiveness so I was wondering what your
thoughts would be on pulling out student
loans again and transferring it's not
paying off my car with those loans with
student loans and possibly getting the
chance to have my car loan that is now
student loan forgiven
so I'm a taxpayer and I'm supposed to
pay off your car with your student loan
forgiveness don't you think that's
immoral
yeah a little bit but at the same time
it's yeah a little bit it's the Opera if
the opportunity is there
um if the government's going to be
deciding to start handing out money left
and right why not take the yeah so um
let me tell you the the there was a book
out several years ago called Millionaire
Next Door by a man named Tom Stanley who
passed away it came out in 1992. he did
a book later called The Millionaire Mind
The Millionaire Next story studied
millionaires A Millionaire Mind he
studied people that had 10 million
dollars deck of millionaires
and he looked for the a character he
looked for the correlating statistical
points he was a researcher and people
that had 10 million or more
and um he found demographic similarities
he found a career similarities and he
found 38
statistical points of reference that
indicated that there were causal that
indicated that if you had a large number
of these you would have a high indicator
that you were heading towards 10 million
or more and he listed them in order of
the of you know the first one in other
words number one was the most often
occurring 38 was the least often
occurring out of the 38 points you
understand what I'm saying and let me
tell you what number one was fanatical
levels of integrity
you need to visit that
and sit on that
because when you do not have fanatical
levels of Integrity you are missing the
number one correlating data point
towards become Building Wealth
versus how much can I scam the American
taxpayer out of and get me a free car
dude that's just wrong yeah
it's just wrong
so no you should not do that a a a
really important mentor of mine posed an
important question back in my 20s and
the question was this
is integrity something you can sort of
have you can mostly have
and that is just sad and sat inside me
for a long long time
because I lived some of my life thinking
yeah I mean mostly you know and here's
the thing
Dave
that Bill's gonna come due for all of us
it's going to come due for all of us
there's just no you you don't nobody
gets Rich scamming the government the
taxpayers no
it's just you don't get wealthy that way
you know you don't get wealthy trying to
you know run a welfare scam
you don't run you don't get wealthy
running up uh unemployment scam you
don't get wealthy scamming the you know
hiding your grandpa's assets so you can
get a government-funded Medicaid nursing
home which is illegal as crud it's
called welfare fraud but people do it
every day and so stealing is not a part
of Integrity why do you think Deca
millionaire is what what's the
correlation there I don't know a lot of
deca millionaires uh
the ones that I know anecdotally line up
with that I mean everybody knows so you
know any group of people you can put
them in a room and there's there's
idiots and everything there's a jerk
right there's somebody that doesn't have
integrity so not all Deca millionaires
do but there's a high correlation of
that that when they interviewed their
wife when they interviewed their kids
when they interviewed their employees
when they interviewed their competitors
in the marketplace they said you know I
don't always agree with that guy but one
thing about it if he says it's raining
you better get your number you know if
he says he if he says he's going to
leave hell on you you better get ready
because hell's coming you know you bet
whatever he says he's going to do he's
going to do and so uh this fanatical
levels of integrity and and I think it's
because most things in this world move
on the Speed Of Trust I was going to say
I think you could probably stumble and
grit and grind and cut and cheat your
way to three million dollars but to get
10 you gotta have other people walking
alongside you gotta have somebody else
lifting with you that's gonna actually
live with you if they don't trust you
yeah and trust is just a it's a mammoth
thing uh and yeah how you get trustful
you're unbelievably consistent and you
know the word integrity comes uh from
the same root word that we get the word
integer from okay or integral okay yeah
and so the word integer if you're a math
nerd you know that an integer is a whole
number it has no fraction
to it it's not 1.5 it's not 1.25 it's a
whole it's two one three it's whole and
integrity is whole the whole person and
it's not like well I don't you know I
don't cheat on my wife but I do cheat on
my taxes you know you're just a freaking
cheat it's just a matter of time before
it's revealed somewhere else it's
because it's that whole and the the
interesting thing about this is the
reason I'm wearing this young man out is
uh directly and indirectly and people in
our audience simultaneously is that it's
a choice
you can grow up being a cheat and just
decide I'm done yeah characters in The
Bible Jacob I'm done Jacob did it yeah
he was known as The Deceiver in the
Bible and then he became a man of
integrity you can just say as of today I
have integrity you can just decide yeah
you can't decide I'm beautiful you can't
decide to grow hair I've tried but you
can just decide I'm going to have
integrity I was going to tell the truth
I'm gonna be a man I'm gonna be a woman
that can be counted on and so I you know
I I you know once I got all that dialed
into my head like you know when I pay
all my taxes every stinking dime I owe
exactly we don't have a side set of
books like we don't count the cash we
count the cash the cash is part of the
profit it's taxable income in America
when you make a cash profit on something
you can hide it but I you but the but
the law says and my Integrity says when
I sign that tax return that it's real
now I hate taxes and I don't pay a dime
more than I have to and I spend money
with accountants trying to legally use
everything in the law to not pay it
right but once I know what's owed I it's
every if if I ever get audited come on
over be a hot knife through butter
because it's it's all right there baby I
got nothing to hide and my guess is your
heart rate runs a little lower you just
a little bit better you sleep at night
you know well the whole thing you know I
don't have to remember what I don't have
to try to remember what I said because
whatever I said was what I said right
huh you know it's like we were digging
around in the warehouse where closed up
a warehouse this week and they brought
some of the old files over and I found a
file in there I was going through them
this morning with my assistant trying to
figure out what to throw away and
there's a file from 1999 with hate mail
and
um
she she gets all my hate mail anyway you
know because they mail it comes here and
so she's like
this is the same thing they say right
now they hate you for exactly the same
reason that they did in 1999 I think we
did we need to read it on the show oh I
do need to do I'll bring the file down
next week we'll do that yeah that's a
good idea
so a couple things in the news we need
to comment on John like last week we
talked about the uh government uh
basically State's Attorneys General
several of them banded together and sued
navient for what it may be one of the
largest settlements in U.S history
navient being required to settle for
1.83 billion dollars
and uh 995 million of that was uh in
restitution 1.7 billion dollars was in
student loans that had to be forgiven
because they were fraudulently made or
fraudulently managed
and we've made a lot of fun with that
and had a lot of fun with that because
it's it's absolutely a bizarre thing
that navient just got they got clocked I
mean they got their clock cleaned one of
the largest billions and billions and
billions navian's forgiveness is now
more than the federal government's
forgiveness of student loans but they
didn't do anything wrong but they didn't
admit anything wrong now here's what's
ridiculous though okay here's how people
here's how the media
and I swear some of you people
so you would think that the headline
would read navient
is a fraudulent scumbag a bunch of
creditors yes that rip people off and
the government took them down instead
CNN says more than 400 000 student loan
borrowers will get debt relief from
navient what a gift like navient is just
a charitable organization thank you CNN
for your misleading headline now when
you read down in the CNN article it
actually does say that they were sued
yeah but you know they are but the
headline is like navient is a charitable
organization oh you know we just thought
we wanted to help because we're just
those kind of people in BC navient plans
to cancel some student loan borrowers
loaned at I wonder who qualifies
headline thanks that's awesome Navi
isn't that great they're just they're
just the best people
you're losing your mind out there
America and why would NBC and CNN do
that you would think they would take the
side of the consumer and go Crux caught
on tape you're your loan might be
forgiven because they were sued into
Oblivion
you know instead it's like navient is
going to help you
it's like
jeez man come on guys you finally get a
real bad guy yeah and you don't even
know what to do with them
the bad guy that you didn't make up you
got a real one and then we let it just
roll off
and then this is this is just
so I'm there was a little uh
kids game
on the internet uh an app or a I don't
even know what it was I think it was
called Animal Farm okay and you would
build your little farm is that right
James it's called Animal Farm
you remember what I'm talking about
Crossing is what we're hearing a new
Crossing or something like that it was
like this Empire thing or something but
you built your farm
and you you tilled the farm and you know
you eventually you know and you made
like
pretend internet money that didn't exist
that's what it is Farmville that's what
it was called and your kid could spend
you know and then it got to where you
could actually go on the site and give
real money to get pretend money to buy a
pretend pick
I make my kids go outside and work a
real Garden but this is like this is
like a virtual Pig it's not a pig okay
it's a virtual Pig it's a pretend Pig it
doesn't really exist it exists only on
the Internet it's not there's no no
oinking no baking gonna happen okay just
a just a it's a virtual Pig it's not
real and you could build your whole Farm
out with this and it was all pretend and
it was all virtual and it was a kid's
game and so I run into this guy at an
entree leadership event and I'm like
it's him the guy that created the game
no no the kid's 19 years old and his
dad's with him and his older brother
who's 26 is there and I'm like so what
kind of business y'all got well we build
um apps for Farmville
and I'm like you mean like add-on like
you don't you don't own Farm Bill no but
we we help people
do better at their Farm their pretend
Farm that's not really there and I'm
like really
and so how much did you make he goes
well I made six million dollars last
year on this app my dad works for me and
so is my older brother he's 19.
and I'm going crazy I thought it was the
neatest
thing that this young entrepreneur could
figure out a way to sell an app on pigs
that aren't really there and get real
money from and got real money
and kids are paying them serious money
to get started what is happening that's
not really there well then it started
occurring to me that we now have an
entire
probably two generations that are raised
up with a screen in front of their face
and to them what's on that screen is as
real as the real thing
when you say virtual to someone my age
it means not real it's a projection it's
sort of it's virtual it's not if I
virtually made it I didn't make it okay
if I if you know I didn't get there you
know I'm saying it's that's the literal
definition you only have a million
dollars no you don't it means you don't
and so
um and so that that's uh that means you
have maybe a little bit less but not
quite you know you're not right it's not
real you're not there and so when you
say virtual now to this entire two
generations to them it's very real
because they've lived their entire life
in it
and so when meta hits
and now we're selling nfts and now
Walmart and Nike and Under Armor are
selling nfts and now you can Walmart's
setting up now for you to have your your
pretend house it's not really there it's
only on the internet like your little
farm bill and if you want to buy pretend
drapes to go in your pretend house
because that's what virtual means it
means pretend not real it's not really
there there's nothing there it's it's
not real it's virtual and but now
Walmart is setting up appears to be
venturing into the metaverse with plans
to create its own cryptocurrency and
collection of nfts the big box retailer
filed several new trademarks last month
that indicates this intent to make and
sell virtual Goods let me help you with
this virtual Goods is an actual oxymoron
if it's a good it's not virtual
and if it's virtual it's not a good a
good this little coffee cup right here
is an actual coffee cup it actually
exists here's some of the goods
including virtual Electronics virtual
home decorations virtual toys virtual
sporting goods and so what we've got is
the kids that grew up playing Farmville
are now going to virtually furnish their
virtual house at Walmart
oh my gosh while they didn't pay off
their student loans they don't even live
in the real world they virtually live
because it's safer in there inside that
little box than it is out here with the
with the crazy but humans with real
drapes that fall off real Windows well
and try hanging real drapes they'll help
you get a divorce but yeah
just I mean but these drapes virtually
hang themselves what's happening this is
yeah yeah unless you have to hire
virtualonias they're not a psychological
disorder at play here dude we we have
I'm showing you it's Escape man it's
escaping into a fantasy world checking
out of the challenges of our real world
and we're going to a place where we can
control the variables because we cannot
do it in our real life that's exactly
right and now we're spending money to do
it real real dog real money for things
that aren't really there there and in
case anyone's forgotten we're in not
real money
to the tune of what 20 25 trillion like
yeah well there's so virtual that we're
just moving into another material
anymore uh well your generation did that
well that's true my generation did do
that last last 10 years we've doubled
the uh you know 10-year look back thing
that's going around yeah you doubled the
uh the debt at the government level
that's another discussion but oh my God
this is so this is uh I I rarely start
saying I'm not saying it's not okay to
play video games and if you want to
spend some money on your video games or
whatever that's fine but when you
psychologically escape to another world
to the point that you don't own real
drapes but you bought grapes in your
pretend house you got issues
electronic Walmart darling it ain't real
so like my Aunt I don't even know what
what do you say to this it's virtual
that's virtually oh this is not real but
it's so interesting because it's the kid
made so much money I'm so enthralled
with it but it's scary about what it
means to about this generation
George is the host of one of the Ramsey
networks Productions called a podcast
called fine print and one of the very
first episodes in the first season of
fine print George pretty much exposed
turgo Turbo Tax as lying
when they said that they were letting
you file your taxes for free George it
appears you have stirred up a problem I
was a fortune teller a prophet no I
think I think you uh I think you stirred
up something I think someone at the
Federal Trade Commission was listening
that's right the Federal Trade
Commission clearly is a big fan of the
fine print and here's proof here's a
headline the FTC sues Turbo Tax to stop
misleading ads for free tax prep
software
wow the Federal Trade Commission said
Tuesday that into its ubiquitous
advertising claiming its Turbo Tax Prep
software is free to use is misleading
kind of what George said
and has asked a federal court to order
into it to stop disseminating the
deceptive claim that consumers can file
their taxes for free using Turbo Tax
according to commission the ads some of
which have consisted almost entirely of
the word free spoke spoken repeatedly
mislead people into believing they can
file their taxes for free with Turbo Tax
in fact most tax filers can't use the
company's free service because it's not
available to millions of taxpayers
such as those who get a 1099
for working the gig economy or who earn
farm income the agency said in a press
release the FTC said in 2020
approximately two-thirds of tax filers
could not use turbo tax's free product
thus it's not free I added that last
part yeah how this is how this works
right yep and uh you know back when we
did this fine print episode this was
back in March 2021 and we sat down me
and you Dave and we went through their
investor day report and it was their
entire strategy about how they're going
to turn their billion dollar company
into a bajillion dollar Company by
becoming one of the biggest lenders out
there they're trying to sell you on debt
and so they lure you in with this
promise of free they end up charging you
because you needed one extra form and
all of a sudden you're you know three
hours in and they go well that'll be 60
bucks that you thought was free and then
later down the road they use all of your
data points to then sell you debt
through all their partners and providers
down the line so all in all not a great
company
turns out into its Turbo Tax is
even when it's free is basically a lead
magnet for
debt products they're Gathering your
data to sell your debt and that's why
that's what they're doing they're using
it to collect that in other words you're
being manipulated in addition to being
misled you are the product that's what
it comes down to
so if you if you needed more ammo here
you can go listen to the whole fine
print episode it's a short one it's
about 20 minutes long or so and we me
and Dave we unpacked their strategy we
talked to some experts we hear some
stories about people who use Turbo Tax
and got screwed and uh the episode's
called how Turbo Tax is screwing you so
I feel like that was pretty apt I think
you uh I really do think somebody at the
FTC was listening to you I hope they're
fans I mean I don't want anything with
it with the you know the acronym coming
after us the IRS the FTC these are scary
people I don't want them on my bad side
the DEA the DEA why are they all three
letters where's this coming from the FBI
the ATF no we don't need any of these
people yes run three letters CIA we
don't want the CIA no no it keeps going
wow three little three-letter Federal
acronyms not good no and yeah Turbo Tax
has been hammered the last few years pro
public I did a huge piece on them about
misleading this even you know Hassan
Patriot acted a whole episode about how
Turbo Tax is hurting people through this
exact thing so I'm glad someone's
finally going after them more
importantly George Campbell did it on
the fine print that's right I'm just
saying that's the one America remembers
into it said in a statement that it will
vigorously challenge the ftc's complaint
claiming arguments are not credible
I think millions of Americans would
disagree with that
so I think it's easy to say they're
credible so in appearance that I did on
Fox television last week
um has been blown up and uh carved up to
the use of left-wing crazies and uh
my Twitter feed is full of things like
this Prince sleeper says uh Dave Ramsey
you're actually a piece of
um blank
LM laugh my
off okay
and so basically I've got a bunch of
juvenile delinquents all over my uh
Twitter left Wingers because I've got
about two national on the national scene
I've got about two on the local scene
I've got about three more uh left wing
Uber Progressive socialist reporters who
detest everything I do and do their best
to write up an article showing that I'm
a knuckle dragging primitive idiot so
because all of this is because I said I
hate the stimulus package because if
1600 1400 or 600 changes your life
you're already screwed you don't have a
life
and that means that Dave Ramsey is a an
old white man that hates everybody and
Dave Ramsey is
um
a uh a piece of blank and uh uh all
because I told some snowflakes they
couldn't get some free money or
shouldn't get some free money from the
government
so let's go and walk through why I would
say something like that is it because
I'm really mean and angry and hate poor
people absolutely not it's absolutely
ridiculous on the contrary I spent my
life helping people get out of debt and
become wealthy and have helped more
people get out of debt and become
wealthy probably than anybody living on
the planet right now
uh we've got 20 million people listening
to this show and podcast on a daily
basis I mean add it up so let's talk
about why I would say that because I am
at war with anything that is going to
keep you with anything or anyone
that is going to keep you
The Listener you the reader
from living in abundance
I want you to win financially
and I am sure after 30 years of teaching
this that personal finance is 80
behavior and twenty percent had
knowledge
and so how you behave
is most of why you are able to build a
life of abundance
starting from nothing which I have done
twice
I started from nothing became a
millionaire by the time I was 28 lost
everything because I was stupid and then
I moved
on and did it again in spades
so
the idea that your behaviors
come from your beliefs
is a big deal what you believe about
life causes you to behave in a certain
way
if you believe that if you step on that
ice and it cracks you're going to fall
through and drown in the in the pond
you're not going to step on the ice what
you believe affects your behaviors it
causes your behaviors all of your
behaviors come from your beliefs so when
you believe something that is false that
is a lie
I am especially when it comes to live
you're living your life in abundance I'm
going to call it out
now if you believe
that the government giving you six
hundred dollars
is going to cause you to live in
abundance
that's ridiculous
but if you believe that then that gives
you permission to sit on your thumb
and not go about taking responsibility
for your own life
mind if you take the six hundred dollars
I'm not mad about that what I am mad
about is this idea that it's going to
fix your life it is not going to fix
your life you are going to fix your life
and until you take personal
responsibility for your life you're
screwed
is there systemic problems with wealth
inequality not as much as the extreme
left thinks because they think it's so
systemic and so overwhelming that you
will not be able to win until wealth is
redistributed
that has never been proven to be true
not in the history of mankind
but if you believe that there are
systemic problems that keep the little
man from getting ahead then you will not
take responsibility for your life and go
win and that makes me angry
and so Chris Hogan and Ramsey Solutions
did a book called everyday millionaires
where we did the largest study of
millionaires showing that 93 of
America's millionaires started from
nothing and received nothing too close
to nothing or receive money after they
were already millionaires they did not
become millionaires mathematically in
the largest airtight study ever done of
millionaires in North America they did
not become millionaires mathematically
because of an inheritance
so if you believe that the only way to
become wealthy is to inherit money
therefore you don't take personal
responsibility for your life I'm gonna
yell at that
for your own good
I'm already a multi-millionaire I'm okay
I don't I'm not a grifter I don't need
your money don't buy my stuff if you're
mad about this it's fine with me don't
listen to the show if you're mad about
this it's fine with me
just don't sign up for stuff I'm fine
with that but everything you're gonna
get from the Ramsey organization is
going to be about you being a grown-up
and taking personal responsibility for
your life if you're waiting on the union
if you're waiting on the government if
you're waiting on your big company if
you're waiting on anything other than
you the person in your mirror to take
responsibility personal responsibility
for your future you are going to fail
you're going to fail because all of
those things are going to let you down
if you believe that the only way to
become wealthy
is to inherit it then you believe a lie
and your belief in that lie causes you
to shut down and not stand up leave the
cave kill something and drag it home and
that pisses me off because it keeps you
from winning
it keeps you from winning if you believe
that the government declaring a 15
minimum wage is going to change your
life very few people get rich on fifteen
dollars an hour
you're gonna have to do better than that
sweet cake
suck it up buttercup
you got to get up leave the cave kill
something and drag it home hustle and
grind
it is your personal responsibility to go
create a life of abundance and when you
think that someone else is going to
cause you to become successful that is
the moment you have signed your death
warrant to the success parade you're not
going to be in it
and so the lefties saying the government
is here to save you
is a lie
now if they send you some money take it
it's one of the few good things they're
ever going to do for you that's fine but
you sitting on your thumb
because you think the government is
going to fix your life you are screwed
okay two years ago right now people were
locked down in their homes we had to
flatten the Curve
you remember flattening the curve well I
remember hearing about it but it turns
out you and I and some Brave staff
people kept coming in and putting out
live shows so I heard about it and we
heard about but the curve apparently had
to be flattened yeah yes and then later
apparently two weeks is when we had to
be mashed and then apparently we didn't
yeah and then apparently we all had to
be vaccinated and then apparently we
didn't and um so people are still
bathing in that fair porn that's out
there yes in the middle of all of that
there's um
a complete I mean we shut down the
American economy yes for you know what
60 to 90 days and we're now experiencing
inflation as a result of that uh lack of
production creating shortages and now a
an over uh uh zealous retail Thrive
driving Supply I mean driving demand way
high in Supply still out of kilter two
years later we're trying to recover from
the flattening of the curve uh but one
of the things I didn't know until I
picked up this from NBC news this week
um they're calling the PPP plan the
biggest
fraud in a generation the Looting of the
covid relief plan that remember PPP oh
yeah where businesses were not going to
you know the economy was going to
collapse if the government didn't step
in right just like we were going to die
we're all going to die if we didn't
flatten the curve right the economy was
going to collapse and everybody was
scared and everybody's running around
screaming and screeching at the top of
their lungs and so the government lines
up
this is blows my mind
um
90 I'm sorry let me see let's just say
okay they bought Lamborghinis they
brought Ferraris and Bentleys here's the
article and Tesla's of course lots of
Teslas many have participated in what
prosecutors are calling the largest
fraud in U.S history the theft of
hundreds of
billions of dollars in tax care payer
money intended to help those harmed
by the covid-19 pandemic
instead these fraudsters came in and
couldn't resist purchasing luxury
automobiles Mansions private jet flights
and swanky vacations they came into the
riches by participating in what experts
say is the theft of as much as 80
billion dollars
80 billion dollars oh yeah of the PPP
was fraudulent use and theft of the 800
billion that was handed out in the
coveted relief plan known as the
paycheck Protection Program or PPP
that's on top of the 90 billion to 400
billion believed to have been stolen
from the other 900 billion under the
coveted unemployment relief program
right so we've got 800 billion and 900
billion we dumped into saving the world
well we have a theme Dave so what
happens is when government says they're
going to come in to save the day
government doesn't operate efficiently
or effectively and what we had was a
small business administration on the
first half of this the PPP saying hey
write us a letter this is a this is
about as fundamental as it was and tell
us why you need it so what do these
people do these scumbags they go let's
take advantage of the US government
because they're a bunch of morons and
we're going to get money and they got it
well and the government just said here's
a check here's a check here's a check
here's a check because they wanted to
save the day exactly well and the Trump
Administration truly believed and they
were screwed in the head that they had
to get this money plugged into the
economy fast to offset the the drop or
to offset the quarantine right and when
you go at that rate of speed you don't
have any way to verify and put in place
that's correct and you drop trillions
and trillions of dollars out there and
now we're finding out that well over 10
percent of it unbelievable north of 500
billion dollars now went to people who
did not have an unemployment problem and
did not even qualify for PPP because all
they did was say
sign this document and check here that
you really are due this money right they
didn't even look no yeah I have 46
employees
I happen to work out of my basement have
no employees but I have 46 employees and
here's the name of my company people
were going to State records and pulling
company names off of State records and
filing under that with false addresses
basically creating a form of identity
theft and getting checks for hundreds of
thousands of dollars sent to them to
keep their business open and they didn't
even have a business yeah this is what
happens when leaders lead from
desperation desperation and fear that's
exactly what happened
it was full-on panic and when people are
panicking they're not leaders that's
correct and I don't care if you're a
Democrat you're a republican you're a
lefty you're a master you're a righty
you're an anti-master you're a vaxxer
you're an anti-vaxxer if you're in a
full-on panic you're straight up stupid
that's right and so what was happening
is the government was trying to give the
illusion of we're in control we got you
and the fact of the matter is they
didn't and this is taxpayer dollars
let's bring this back to when you hear
numbers like that I want to make sure
you folks catch this because those
numbers are so big it kind of feels like
oh it's that's just so that's your money
that is taxpayer dollars being
fraudulently spent and all because
leaders are trying to give the illusion
that they can solve your problems and by
the way they're the source of the
shutdown where the governors
and the Senators Trump all of them they
all signed on to this shutdown and it
broke businesses and in their desire to
help the businesses they broke
they ended up wasting money and I got to
tell you something it ought to be a
wake-up call to the American got to stop
and go hey yeah this is this whole thing
yeah was off yeah and let's stop blaming
it's just some kind of bad movie right
here but
500 billion dollars paid out to people
that didn't even own businesses or that
weren't even unemployed
in the name of panic
brought on by
false sets of assumptions about numbers
oh God it just is it's a it's a case
study in leadership not leading and in
the nanny stake run amok that's true and
and so the people are screaming you have
to take care of us because now you've
made us locked us in our house and now
you have to feed us and uh man people
you people I'm telling you if you ever
allow your government to do this to you
again you're a bunch of freaking sheep
but yeah because this the the results of
this
are going to Ripple through our economy
for a decade
yeah 100
million dollars and here's the deal you
can do something
you know what you can do vote go vote
anybody that was a party to this kind of
Google
to a governor to a senator to a
president you can vote send them home
good God
so George the producer James just
handled us an article
it's juicy it's a juicy one
well
okay
this pisses me off all right because
the um
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
brought to you by Elizabeth Warren
that's where it came from
um was put in place to protect the
consumer
they were put in charge of a piece of
legislation that's been in place for 30
or 40 years
called the federal fair debt collection
practices Act
there's federal law that dictates how
collectors have to behave or they're in
violation of federal law when they're
trying to collect from you
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
is in charge of the federal debt fair
debt collection practices act
regulations and fines and you know you
know basically protecting the consumer
so what did they do
under this Administration
decided to help out the collectors
instead of the consumer
so they just
new rules approved by the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau that took
effect this is from NPR that took effect
on Tuesday dictate how collection
agencies can email or text people as
well as message them on social media to
collect unpaid debts so now they can
hassle you on Twitter
your Facebook account text you and email
you
we're a part of protection at the bureau
did they not get they just unleashed the
hounds on the Consumer Financial
Protection
Bureau you need to read the title of the
place you work
good God I thought it was bad enough
when my mom joined Facebook
and now the collectors are on there too
the whole game
you can't stop Everyone's Watching You
George
you know a way to fix this is don't be
on Facebook but yeah
good luck well it's easier now
everyone's going you know they're on
Instagram you have to have something
like I've got where I pay people to do
this stuff because I can't stand it but
this is what's crazy it says they can
attempt to join your network by sending
you a friend request and they must give
you the option to opt out of being
contacted online and any messages they
send do have to be private so they're
not going to go posting on your public
page Dave don't worry yeah that would be
a violation of privacy act a whole other
Act
the rules are really disappointing and
concerning in a number of ways as April
neuhoff a staff attorney for the
National Consumer Law Center hello April
that's an understatement
uh yeah disappointing no this is just
ridiculous this is what we in the South
call we just let the fox in the hen
house that's a good saying I like that
one here's what's crazy we are going to
see so much spam come out of this it
says allowing debt collectors to email
text and use social media to contact
consumers also gives criminals a new
Avenue to try to Swindle people out of
their money and practice canoehoff
expects to increase in the future all
right I get a bunch of crap on my Apple
phone updates
that I don't want and they force it on
me and I have to go in and turn it off
or turn it on and so that people aren't
watching me and all this other bull crap
all these things they do with this
technology I'm getting just paranoid but
they're gonna have to put a thing on the
Apple phone
oh yeah block collector text select on
or off
and that maybe you know there you go
that'll work
so um I did just somebody to show me the
damn I'm some technology you're gonna
look at me because you know I'm stupid
but um yeah you can turn off uh not the
phone doesn't ring if it's an
unrecognized numbers because the 73 000
calls I get a year on my uh warranty for
my car that I need to buy which is
hilarious you're calling Dave Ramsey's
phone I mean come on but um yeah I mean
all those are blocked now and so
automatically they don't it doesn't ring
my phone's like we're gonna have to have
that selection for collectors Apple's
gonna have to protect us because the
Protection Bureau won't protect us oh
boy and you know the weird thing about
sliding into the DMS here on on your
Instagram account if the only people
sliding into the DMS are the collectors
that's a sad life we got to pay off this
debt get rid of it leave them on red you
can't ghost these people
they're gonna be after you
that sums it up
[Music]
hope you enjoyed this episode if you did
click here for the next one where you're
going to hear stories of the wealthiest
celebrities getting caught in the act of
outrageous generosity